[Música]
dice que la sonrisa es el idioma de las
personas inteligentes yo cuando el
everton en voz alta por si acaso sonrío
lo empiezo a hablar se disipa las dudas
hoy es hoy cómicos hoy conmigo me
encanta la comedia con esta cara tampoco
tenía muchas salidas pero me gusta la
comedia y no siempre fue así lo decía
guillem no yo estudié derecho y al poco
de acabar me metí en el mundo comercial
12 años de comercial 12 años de
comercial estuve en cuatro tipos de
empresas
estuve una empresa multinacional me fue
luego la empresa nacional estuve en una
pyme acabe en una micropyme y ahora soy
autónomo
yo para arriba siempre
[Aplausos]
y es curioso porque ser comercial o sea
me ha enseñado a leer a la gente no a
tratar con la gente pero ser cómico me
ha ayudado a conectar con las personas y
si de algo me da cuenta últimamente es
que la gente ríe muy poco es más ríe
como hacia adentro
me pasa yo estoy actuando y viene me
gusta mucho el monólogo en qué momento
señora si no me enteramos no hay que ir
hacia afuera esto esto es pasa a mí me
da mucho la atención
de hecho ha enviado atención porque a mí
la comedia me dio la vida bueno la vida
me salvó la vida concretamente la pierna
yo me rompí el ligamento cruzado jugando
y bueno pues clínica quirón me operan y
esto fue tal cual estaba en quirófano y
vida de operación de la operación pues
bueno pues me despierto año 2012
claro veo aquella tela verde no que te
ponen para no ver lo que están haciendo
el otro lado y yo creo que pensé os lo
juro fue a ver si con tanto recorte
se han quedado justo de anestesia esta
gente
lo que me hizo que mi cerebro hizo lo
prometo fue tirada de humor porque pensé
como les aviso que me estoy despertando
a lo mejor te con grito y me cortado un
tendón y digo yo
ya sea que la mano por un lado
hice este gesto como diciendo que me
estoy despertando tranquilo estoy
experta aparece la enfermera estás bien
digo estoy despierto
no sé si es bueno o malo no tienes cara
de san pedro dice no te preocupes dice
que ya estamos acabando digo que no
tengo prisa no me espera nadie bueno se
pusieron a reír la enfermera al cirujano
ja ja ja ja ja ja je je pero acaba del
remiendo bien y luego ya no
ahí fue donde yo descubrí bueno grandes
verdades la primera que cualquier sitio
y cualquier momento es bueno para reír e
incluso un quirófano no me digáis que no
es algo menos divertido que un quirófano
que puede haber bueno haciendo pero
también riendo y en ellos
un poco claros pensarlo bien siete meses
de baja siete meses de baja cada día
hacía cuatro horas de rehabilitación se
dice pronto claro yo allí tuve una
decisión personal digo porque yo sabía
que el tiempo que va a estar ahí iba a
ser el mismo me lo tomara bien o me lo
tomara mal yo decidí porque al final
esto es una decisión personal tomármelo
bien con humor cada mañana cachondeo
concurso de chiste porque llevaba música
y pensé este este paso voy a cobrar
entrada a la gente y fue allí donde
amigos amigas descubrir mi vocación hace
reír lo que me hacía feliz era hacer
reír es bonito que cuando uno siente con
que está conectado con su esencia no mi
pasión era esa así claro tenía dos
opciones o me rompo está rodilla para
seguir estando la crítica o dejo el
trabajo pues tarde esto en dejar el
trabajo volví y además me acuerdo el
momento
el lector comercial con una reunión y
dijo una frase que aún la recuerdo dice
y juegos y cómo pensar muy bien dónde
quieres estar el año que viene
yo pensé aquí no
digno
y debe llegar desde el trabajo y no es
que y es curioso porque paradójicamente
siento cómico trabajó mucho para
empresas ahora no maestro de ceremonias
monólogos un poco de todo y me da cuenta
de algo que es que la gente no ríe las
empresas hace falta mucho humor de las
empresas la gente va con una cara de
amargado los trabajadores hay algunos
que van con cara de zombie por las
mañanas hay gente que no puede hablar es
porque te muerden astra ti de la mañana
toma té el café nene porque o sea no es
normal y yo a veces lo pienso digo si
pasamos la mitad del día en el trabajo
no es buen sitio para reír no es acaso
un buen lugar para pasarlo bien no acaso
un trabajador feliz no es un trabajador
eficiente yo seguro que algunos diréis
hoy es que esto de trabajar y pasárselo
bien son conceptos que apesta la cabeza
ya pero por qué no porque no yo tenía un
compañero que con el rey a mucho porque
llegaba abajo os ha pasado que llegaba
cada uno de enero 2 de enero
volvíamos de vacaciones de navidad
y yo le decía feliz año qué tal estaba
dice muy mal
digo porque dice lo sabes este año
navidad que el sábado
ya estás mirando el calendario nena
[Música]
en serio que yo no entiendo a ver que yo
lo entiendo que todo mundo vamos a
estresados la presión que si los jefes
que la sociedad ha cambiado ha
evolucionado las tecnologías estoy de
acuerdo pero lo que lo único que no ha
cambiado es la capacidad que tenemos las
personas de modificar y mejorar el
estado de ánimo del resto cómo se hace
esto normalmente o como mínimo con una
sonrisa una sonrisa para arrancar
sorpresas no hace falta ser cómico yo sé
medio graso risas como el reflejo de la
actitud que hay detrás y hay dos tipos
de personas para mí que reflejan esto
está la gente y la gente
la gente busca esta gente la gente que
tenga por teléfono
ahora no
que la de venir a hacer
y cruzar de acera expert prefiriendo que
te atropelle un camión gente que tiene
un mal rollo una energía deudas que
están soportando resistiendo aguantando
las bajas de castellet yo no lo entiendo
sea
que está soportando no lo entiendo luego
está la gente y gente positiva como tal
y como a todo en un abrazo gente
positiva que te inyecta un poquito eso
me ayuda un camarero que trabaja en mi
barrio que sentido por excelencia tú
entras en la cafetería por la mañana da
igual si llueve da igual si es lunes su
actitud tú entras y dice buenos días
caballero que le pongo eso
pues lo mismo que las tomate lo mismo
que te has tomado tú
gracias
verdad
entonces mi pregunta es antes de seguir
con esto porque mejor de sentido cuánta
gente hay hoy aquí por una trama no
urgente
hay algunos declarado
si no tiene que abandonar la sala y no
queremos gente así
hoy pero fíjate un dato que me llamó la
atención
sabías que cuando los niños los niños
ríen de media 200 veces al día y los
adultos sólo 15 que digo 15 siendo
generoso
hay gente que ríe 15 en un mes que lip
que nos pasa pero vamos a ver estamos
todos de acuerdo que la risa es positiva
si es saludable no oxígeno al cerebro no
fortalece el sistema inmunológico no
segrega dopamina serotonina eleva la
autoestima dicen que las personas más
atractivas son la gente con las personas
que sonríen yo como estoy soltero desde
que me enteré de este dato hoy con unas
sonrisas pegadas por la calle parezco el
deshollinador de mary poppins
pero por qué
y yo lo pienso digo
qué nos está pasando en qué momento
dejamos de reír o pasarlo tan bien como
que tenemos pequeños no lo entiendo
supongo que alguien cuando no hemos
creciendo nos inculcó esa idea de no
para ser una persona respetada no hay
que ser serio y responsable mira
responsable sí pero serio porque es
serio para mí lo más serio que hay es el
humor el humor es muy serio porque te
alarga la vida te alarga la vida os lo
prometo yo soy pienso que una persona
empieza envejecer cuando se olvida del
niño que habita en el claro porque está
la gravedad porque tú no estás
compartiendo lo que tienes sonriendo
hacia afuera compartiendo esa amabilidad
todo eso es un regalo que te haces lo
decía a jodorowsky lo que das te lo das
lo que no das te lo quitas hay un dicho
precioso que es budista y dice procura
dejar a la persona que te encuentras por
el camino mejor de cómo te la
encontraste
cómo se hace eso una sonrisa una sonrisa
probadlo yo a veces voy a un
supermercado y si ven me fijo en los
cajeros o las cajeras nadie les hace ni
caso nadie ni los saludan yo llegó allí
y te hacen esa pregunta inquietante de
bolsa grande o pequeña
bueno mi idea está pillado y con el
móvil yo siempre me miro el nombre digo
marta
asesora me tú que eres la experta en la
materia
se empodera hace
con la pequeña suficiente
y no cuesta nada este gadget
no cuesta nada ser amable mira voy a
contar la cosa que pasó y esto es real
tal cual se mejor coche la grúa
soy cómico pero también vemos que hasta
200.000 las multas me duelen como a
todos llegó allí y no había ni pegatina
claro estuve 20 minutos llamando un
depósito al otro está mi coche lo
encuentro cuando fui hacia a recoger el
coche me hice este planteamiento
yo pensé cómo voy a afrontar este
momento quiero decir esta persona que me
reciba no tiene culpa de que se me llevó
el coche de la grúa sin embargo está
debajo no hay problemas y letras desde
cristal antibalas no te vayas recibiendo
ahí las malas energías llegó allí bueno
tenía un tío delante estaba que subía
por las paredes y yo hice lo contrario y
digo buenos días
te cuento
anoche tenía mi coche aparcado un sitio
y esta mañana
ya no estaba y como no he dejado de
pensar
esta noche y tú tienes pinta de saber
dónde está
que sí que sí
y él
gracias
debo decir la reacción suya fue de con
estas guardias
no hay un psicópata
pero luego empezó a reír ya reír y
vengar ja ja je je es más cerró la
garita y me acompañe a buscar el coche
en persona porque porque alguien fue
amable con esa persona que cuesta ser
amable en los dos casos alguien fue
amable compartimos esa sonrisa hacia
afuera esa amabilidad y ese pedido que
la habilidad o la sonrisa es como un
boomerang no siempre regresa a ti con la
misma energía y la misma intensidad con
la que fue lanzada que es verdad a ver
que hay gente que merece esta cara de
tira del govern que la cabeza que la
verdad es verdad pero pensarlo esa gente
es gente que no se permite reír
necesitan el humor más que nadie se lo
pensar lo necesita el humor más que
nadie al final esto el humor es muy
sencillo es un sencillo se trata de
compartir de hacer a la gente no la vida
un poquito más llevadera a uno mismo y
haces lo pienso digo si es que al final
fijaros lo que voy a decir fijaros
somos las sonrisas
somos las sonrisas que generamos en el
resto
cuando nos recuerdan
cuando nos recuerdan al final todo esto
es muy sencillo y lo resumen es el
siguiente cada día cuenta cada momento
es bueno decía buda el problema hasta
que pensamos que tenemos tiempo no lo
tenemos hay que reír cada día cada
momento cuenta porque no cada momento
cuenta amigos por eso desde el corazón
no lo digo y de este sitio maravilloso
amigos amigas sigamos riendo sigamos
riendo hacia afuera porque quien ríe
poco vive a medias como queréis vivir
vosotros gracias
[Aplausos]